[Musique]
il ne reste que quelques minutes avant
le départ
le temps des derniers réglages pour
rester le blond 24 ans elle va
participer à une course mythique sur
l'île de man
la tourist trophy appelé titi reis une
compétition complètement folle elle a
même été exclu du championnat du monde
de moto en 1976 de faire un devis n'est
justement pas trop
trait sur ce qui va venir non plus parce
que
passion donc
reste elle est la patronne de son side
car elle a réussi à s'imposer dans ce
monde d'hommes
elles ne sont que deux femmes pilotes
sur la course avec son coéquipier elle
se dirige vers la ligne de départ ici
estelle est déjà une star à
l'entraînement vous étiez beaucoup plus
rapide que votre père
m
[Musique]
lawrence à sponsors la met en garde sur
les dangers du circuit on fait attention
de bien prendre sur la gauche virage car
il ya une grosse flaque d'huile
[Musique]
les concurrents partent un à un c'est
une course contre la montre
[Musique]
l'île de man une petite région autonome
de la couronne britannique
c'est ici qu'a lieu chaque année la
titille reiss depuis 1907 200 pilotes
professionnels et amateurs s'affrontent
pendant 15 jours sur motos et side car
un tracé atypique
la compétition n'a pas lieu sur un
circuit mais sur les petites routes
départementales de lille 61 kilomètres
parcourus à plus de 200 km heure de
moyenne avec des pointes à 300 km heure
le tout avec une sécurité réduite à tout
moment les pilotes peuvent taper un
trottoir ou un spectateur la titille
reis réputée pour être une des courses
les plus dangereuses du monde
il y a des morts parmi les pilotes
presque chaque année
240 morts depuis sa création
[Musique]
chaque faute de conduite se paye cash
courir à la titille reis c'est mettre sa
vie en danger c'est l'everest des
pilotes de moto
[Musique]
mirabel haut maroni à 10 minutes de
vaison la romaine dans le sud de la
france
une semaine plus tôt
nous avions vu estelle chez elle le jour
de son départ pour l'île de man la
titille reis a toujours été la course de
ses rêves
bah c'est tout ce qu'un coureur moto
sicard cherche c'est ça c'est de
l'adrénaline parce que ça va vite parce
que c'est beau parce que ça à 24 ans
estelle est une surdouée du sport moto
en 2012
elle a été la première femme championne
de france de side car dans la vraie vie
elle est assistante vétérinaire
la moto c'est sa passion une passion
transmise par son père qui lui a
construit son premier side pour ces
quatre ans chez lesquels j'étais pote
jamais été très grande mais là j'étais
encore patrick on est située sur manquer
ainsi car que mon papa il vous avez
construit c'était le lancement c'était
parti une passion familiale ses deux
parents ont déjà gagné de nombreux
trophées à l'attirail ce sont des
trophées des répliques de trophées
suzanne lainesse donc c'est un trophée
qu'ils remettent uniquement femme s'est
fait uniquement féminin sylvie la maman
a raccroché
mais françois le papa va encore
concourir cette année toute la famille
parents camping-car pour 15 jours de
course
voilà ce qu'attend notre participation
et il ya des choses que j'ai compris
deux trois quatre ans après tout si on
m'avait dit tout de suite dépassé pour
ça d'économisé qu'on entend donc de
sécurité de ça de bon conseil
apparemment les anglais ont déjà donné
un surnom estelle the woman burns
s'était c'était là la femme la femme
cool retour à l'île de man au lever du
soleil
nous retrouvons estelle elle quitte le
paddock sur la pointe des pieds
ces cinq heures du matin tout le monde
dort donc on ne meurt pas le moteur dans
le paddock avec estelle refait le
parcours et les 240 virage du circuit
comme tous les jours un travail
minutieux pour grappiller quelques
précieuses secondes à chaque tour
après l'entraînement à moto les conseils
auprès de papa en voiture donc là tu
chopes le mur tu sembles mur doit la
petite erreur c'est là dans la bagnole
d'un léger gauche obtient peu mais c'est
ces grands singes et tu sors un peu
large
par contre faut que je revienne vite au
milieu pour la bosse il est vital de
prendre des repères car voilà ce que ça
donne exactement au même endroit à 200
km
[Applaudissements]
estelle est de retour dans les paddocks
elle bichonne son engin si on passe plus
de temps à travailler dessus car rouler
si on les regarde jamais pensé au cube
cantonales temps on risque de passer à
côté de problèmes qui pourraient créer
des femmes et donc du coup c'est
maintenant le temps des derniers essais
estelle doit faire un bon chrono pour se
qualifier pour la course derniers
encouragements de la famille dans le
side car estelle et la pilote sébastien
et son indispensable coéquipiers sa
mission équilibrer la machine et la
maintenir sur la rouge un rôle vital à
plus de 180 km heure de moyenne chaque
boss devient un obstacle mortels
sébastien s'aplatit à quelques
centimètres de la route
pour maintenir le side en équilibre
[Musique]
fin des essais maman vient lui annoncer
son temps de course 22 minutes 16 pour
les 61 kilomètres ça suffit quand même
pour participer à la course petit
débriefing avec papa lui aussi qualifié
[Musique]
quarante mille motards ont débarqué pour
assister à la compétition pendant quinze
jours
l'île vit au rythme de la course sur ce
terrain de foot transformé en camping
pour les fans de la titille un groupe de
français et lyon parmi eux damien
contremaître à vendôme
ils économisent toute l'année pour ce
voyage au taf avant de partir à matin tu
vas encore au 2 août et 8 mois encore à
lui demande si voilà il y en a tous les
dimanches suivants à la messe
ma morale c'est maintenant c'est d'aller
tous les ans au kiki
les gens sont les domaines cela fait 5
ans qu'il vient ici chaque matin avec
ses copains il part à la recherche de
sensations sur le circuit pour décrire
ce qu'ils veulent ce que l'on vit ici ce
que l'on voit tu vas pas tu vois ça d'un
parcours
objectif trouver les meilleurs spots
pour prendre des photos des pilotes au
plus près de la course
damien a repéré un joli virage
à la titille les spectateurs se mettent
n'importe où malgré le danger
il ya du risque comme tous les pilotes
dix personnes les oblige à monter sur
les chinois nous personne nous oblige à
nous mettre comme l'a6 sur la mousse à
20 centimètres de la route
pour eux c'est un bon spot les pilotes
prennent toujours ce virage à fond même
pendant les essais comme aujourd'hui
et ça ne rate pas damien et ses potes
sont là depuis moins de deux heures
quand soudain [ __ ] c'est ma jambe
on s'en occupe comment tu t'appelles
andy
le pilote est venu percuter le bord de
la route à 280 km heure les sauveteurs
doivent travailler en évitant les motos
[Musique]
priorité à la course
la compétition n'est pas arrêté les
bolides ralenti sa tenue on donne un
coup de main comme on peut au marshall
on dit d'un peu les pilotes pour éviter
justement un autre accident
sous la violence du choc la moto a été
coupée en deux par miracle le pilote a
survécu
il n'a qu'une jambe cassée une fois
l'urgence passée
damien va voir le reste de la bande ça
fait froid dans le dos un autre français
a lui aussi eu beaucoup de chance
il a pris sa dernière photo juste avant
que la moto ne percute le mur est devant
lui d'après j'étais par terre j'ai sauté
pendant ce temps là le pilote est évacué
vers un hôpital en angleterre
et ce n'est pas le seul accident sur le
circuit nous retrouvons estelle très
tendu elle refuse de nous en parler
c'est dans son paddock que nous
apprenons la mauvaise nouvelle
non de procès qui viennent mourir merde
franck petricko la 32 ans un pilote
chevronné il vient de se tuer sur le
circuit
martin et son sponsor et son ami il
avait fait une petite vidéo de franck la
veille de sa mort la titille reis le
faisait rêver
c'était sa première fois je savais que
c'était unique au monde mais je pensais
pas à ce point en fait c'est vraiment
incroyable
je pense que toutes les difficultés
possibles et imaginables sont réunis ici
tout est concentré sur 60 km et c'est
vraiment génial quoi on le voit avec le
gilet orange des nouveaux coureurs sur
ces images il prend le départ pour ce
qui sera sa dernière course il mourra
quelques minutes plus tard en ratant un
virage
c'est le jour j
le jour de la course pour estelle et son
père la tension monte
eh bien
pas
la la
ce qu'on l'a permis et
on se retrouve tous à la fin de la
course pour voir intense
c'est une course contre la montre mais
side prennent le départ un par un toutes
les dix secondes
[Musique]
reste elle roule bien mais le side-car
de son père françois ne réapparaît pas
s'ils vivent a ouvert
il avait été arrêté à ginger rôle
immédiatement imagine le pire
arrêtez ça veut tout et rien dire s'ils
sont en panne
voilà ce pass session mais c'est pas
grave
j'espère que c'est juste là une casse ou
compagnon
enfin après de longues minutes son
mécano reçoit un coup de téléphone
étaient franches ils ont cassé une roue
sur fond crotoy le stress évacué la
route
faut juste que la hâte de prendre ce
train ça devient agaçant à la fin
[Musique]
ap
l'infinie donc on est content de passer
un peu
comme un match de rugby puis c'était moi
le ballon
estelle est arrivé en 18e position sur
61 mais elle aura droit à un lot de
consolation est elle a troqué sa
combinaison pour une robe elle va
recevoir le prix du pilote le plus
méritant c'est la femme la plus rapide
du circuit
la conduite moins vite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore un trophée pour la famille le blu
prochain objectif pour estelle gagner la
titille reis
à 24 ans elle a encore des années pour y
croire